of it.
And so
I just want to be sure, but
will
we continue this conversation that, that you
understand that the moment a democrat becomes
president again, Republicans will take the
smallest thing and impeach that president.
Okay.
That being said, here's Nancy Pelosi.
Um, uh, and, and she's in the interview with,
uh, Mika Brzezinski from a morning Joe, and
this is what she had to say in response to
representative Amash has a stance, the Republican
who has come out in favor of impeachment,
take a listen
it, Justin Amash has position on impeachment.
He's tweeted more today.
He's coming right back at the president.
Does it, does it fit the bar for bipartisan
support for impeachment as my coach and support
from patient has to be in the Senate?
Yeah.
In terms of constantly mad, his voice speaks
to the silence of so many other, all the other
Republicans not to hold this president accountable
for the oath of office that he takes to protect
and defend the constitution.
Perspecting coequal branches of government.
So, uh, uh, may be one voice by the fact that
it is the absence of other voices.
It speaks very loudly.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It looks to me that Nancy Pelosi is, is doing
everything she can to avoid impeachment because
that's not an excuse, right?
What that, what the Senate does, you know,
she's trying to say, unless we can guarantee
a conviction, right?
A conviction on the articles of impeachment
that the house would draw up unless we can
guarantee a conviction and which work would
require bipartisanship than she's not going
to do it.
But what does that say about American democracy
when the body that is responsible for holding
the president accountable is afraid to do
so because of political reasons, right?
She's going to say it in the next clip that
it's not about politics, but clearly she's
avoiding impeaching Donald Trump as a, at
least drawing up articles of impeachment and
passing them in the house.
She's avoiding that because she doesn't think
she has the politics, the P uh, the political
capital or, or the, uh, the majority of that
she needs in the Senate as she believes that
it's going to backfire.
Right?
So those are clearly political calculations.
And so she's doing the exact opposite of what
she's saying she's doing.
But that's nothing new.
That's Politics One oh one.
But take a listen to the second clip.
Uh, and her response to makers.
A very direct question.
So doesn't it put more pressure on you?
Is that a conservative Republican says the
threshold for impeachment has been met?
No.
No, no.
Why?
But we have to.
We're not, this isn't about politics.
It's not about passion.
It's not bad prejudice.
It's not about politics.
It's about patriotism.
And it's about the presentation of the facts
so that the American people can see why we're
going down a certain path.
I'm sorry, but this absolutely a representative
image.
His move should absolutely put the onus and
the responsibility squarely in her lap.
She's saying that it's not about politics,
but as I already stated, this is clearly about
politics.
She doesn't want any backlash, but, but let's
remember back when Bill Clinton was impeached,
the Republicans won everything in the following
and the subsequent election, right?
The problem is that Democrats do have the
backbone that is necessary to play the type
of politics that are going on right around
us right now.
Right?
This, this is a, this is an extreme matter
of fact.
Before I finish that sentence lie, I want
to make something clear.
Republicans have been playing hardball politics
for a very long time.
They have been cut throat, no prisoners, zero
sum game for a very long time.
And the fact that Democrats are still trying
to, um, uh, place civility politics, right?
The fact that Joe Biden is coming out saying
he wants to work with Republicans shows that
there's a class of Democrats who are extremely
unequipped to fight this present fight.
And this isn't a question like I normally
would do.
Like if you watch my show, I deal with a centrism
versus leftism.
But this has nothing to do with that because
you have a lot of establishment democrats
who are coming out in favor and move impeachment.
You also have some, some leftists Democrats
who are coming out in favor of impeachment.
So you have in a sense bipartisanship on this
in the divide on the left, right, the divide
that exist on the left of the spectrum.
There's clearly a call for impeaching Donald
Trump.
The evidence suggests that he should be impeached
and whether or not you can win in the Senate
is, is sort of irrelevant because Nancy Pelosi's
job isn't to worry about the Senate.
Her job is to fulfill her duties as the house,
uh, as a speaker of the House
of Representatives.